good morning everyone
so John John mate Graf made a good point
to me during the break right before this
that not I I sort of casually use you
know public servants public employee
unions government worker unions all
interchangeably but not everybody
actually really understands that when
people talk about public employee unions
or public unions because the word public
gets used for everything in this country
and in the dialogue you know regardless
of whether things are actually public
when we're talking about public employee
unions we're talking about government
unions so this is you know this is not
Teamsters this is not you know janitors
this is government workers unions and
and so the first the first thing is you
know there's this this this is obviously
not probably the conception of folks in
this room of what our public servants
but I think it's kind of the traditional
concept of public servants and so
they're they're folks that you know take
pretty crappy jobs because they you know
they want to make life better for
everybody else and I will say I have you
know a fair number of friends and
acquaintances that work for the
government and some are actually like
that some actually are doing things that
are relatively in the more relatively
sensible end of the spectrum of things
that government does and they really are
you know pretty much motivated by trying
to you know make things work
and but then so it's it's not per se the
workers though there are plenty of
government workers who are venal or
cognitively constrained as Julian put it
but but you know what's the problem
really is the unions and these are
organizations that represent these
workers whose mission is to oppose the
taxpayers and get a better deal for
their members that's their job is to
negotiate against the taxpayers for a
worse deal for taxpayers and a
a deal for their members seems like
that's not really in the public interest
for such things to exist and yet somehow
these two things get conflated but I
want to break down that assertion in a
much more direct way this idea that
government workers are they're serving
the public's interest so a few things
this is this is I put this up first this
is almost my favorite that federal
workers far more likely to die on the
job than get fired there is you know
this idea that your context caught that
unions are constantly trying to
repudiate that oh you really you can
fire a government worker everybody knows
you can well maybe we can but we
certainly don't because if they're
croaking faster than they're being fired
for performance you know there's
something going on there and the you
know the comparison there on the last
bullet is in the private sector you know
it's not a massive number anybody who's
an employer knows you don't fire a whole
lot of people it's a relatively small
percentage that just don't perform and
have to be let go 3% that's still vastly
more hmm let's see we've got a a point
10.1 eight percent in the federal
government for at least the high high
paid notice also how much of the ones
who actually do get laid off get laid
off in the first two years so it's not
actually performance it's bumping its
when got most of the time when the
government lets people go it's because
of a budget crunch and they let the most
recent employees go first regardless of
performance so it's even worse than it
looks in these outrageous statistics
wages and benefits you know point out
that video two things about that video
Chris Reid who has subsequently left the
San Diego union-tribune and now
full-time blogs just on California
stupidity essentially his so he has a
lot of material and but he made the
comment about the fact that the wage
disparity argument is no longer true
that we don't have to give outrageous
benefits to public workers because
they're not grossly underpaid and I'm
gonna break that down in several ways
the other thing I'll point
is that carl demaio the mayoral
candidate there is a fantastic guy a he
used to work with reason years ago
before he went into politics he's he's
he's a gay republican who's actually a
libertarian
he's just God he's God and and he's you
know he's a fiend you saw he actually
writes this stuff he writes like Policy
Studies I mean how many politicians are
actually that much that intellectually
into you know budget and fiscal issues
pretty good actually yeah so a you know
he's really champing a lot of policy
change even even as he's running for
office don't we wish Romney was actually
trying to get some of the things done
that he talks about while he's
campaigning you know DeMaio is actually
running ballot initiatives and trying to
get things done while he's a council
member and running for mayor he's not
wait until he's mayor and just making
promises anyway back to the wages so
here's one one way of slicing it and
this is you know Department of Labor
Statistics and you can see pretty
straightforwardly in a very aggravated
way no evidence that government is
underpaid here's another this is USA
Today lined up workers and divided them
into categories of similar so secretary
is compared to secretaries managers
compared to managers janitors compared
to janitors kind of thing and still
found a huge pay premium for being in
the federal government slicing it yet
another way or this is actually still
the USA Today but then they they broke
it down you know by pay brackets and the
most interesting is is of course the
most highly paid workers but the the
killer thing here is it between 2005 and
2010 okay so you realize there's two
years of non recession there and three
years of recession and yet the number of
really highly paid federal workers just
skyrocketed this is your stimulus
dollars at work because most of the
stimulus money went to federal agencies
to hire more people and they
hired really highly paid people I we
might be stuck with those people for the
next 20 years too and then this is the
latest thing just a couple of weeks ago
CBO came out with a report contact
Congress requested saying okay we want
you to look at this by educational
treatment because the response to the
USA Today was well yeah but the workers
in the government are on average much
more highly educated than workers in the
private sector and that's why even
though they have the same job they're
getting paid more so CBO said well ok
let's take a look at that and what you
can see is that it's something we at
reason if known for a long time due to
our privatization work is that the
government over pays less educated
people and under pays highly educated
people so basically when you privatize
generally speaking unskilled people lose
out and skilled people benefit at least
as far as the workers who have to
transfer from the government to the
private sector this is equally true for
state government by the way in general
but you know to a slight extent this is
where you kind of have the real public
servants in the sense of my first slide
these are people who actually take a hit
in pay and benefits in order to work in
the public sector
unfortunately these these kind of people
tend to be much more political
appointees senior bureaucrats and people
who are getting perhaps non-pecuniary
benefits from being in those jobs like
they took this job for three or four
years and then doubled their salary
going back to the private sector with
all that experience working at EPA or
whatever becoming a lobbyist there's a
lot of soon-to-be lobbyists in that
column right there I could tell you ok
so leaving aside salary comparisons
pensions and I've talked several times
at Reason weekend about pensions we we
track this pretty regularly both in the
policy division and an unreasoning and I
thought this is just interesting because
this is just a timeline of studies so ok
pew in 2008 says there's a 1 trillion in
unfunded liabilities for pension to
health care two years later
two trillion same year different
calculation mostly keep by by doing a
better job of incorporating the state
and local governments three and a half
trillion a even more detailed analysis
done by these two university professors
that took into account the these numbers
accepted rosy market return scenarios by
a lot of pension funds these guys
actually broke down said well what if
they actually earn something more
reasonable in terms of their rate of
returns what do we get and we get so
let's just say there's a trend here
there's a lot of unfunded liabilities
and they're probably a hell of a lot
more than anybody realizes even at this
point because that's only state
governments if somebody did this style
of analysis on state local and federal
we're probably pushing something
god-awful like eight eight to ten
trillion so now one of the government
workers are getting paid more and
getting these outrageous pension
benefits that create these huge unfunded
liabilities they're aided and abetted by
our elected officials because generally
elected official well almost without
exception elected officials are not part
of public employee unions those are the
actual folks in the bureaucracy the
elected officials are not part of that
system but they're the ones who
allegedly are the bargainers on behalf
of the taxpayers in that little
bargaining picture I painted at the
beginning so our elected officials are
supposed to sit down across the table
from their employees and bargain against
them for wages and benefits on behalf of
the taxpayers well you know they see
taxpayers once or twice a week every day
they mingle with their workers so to
speak I mean it's different for
different different government folks but
let's just say they it doesn't take very
long in office to feel a lot closer to
the staff than you do to the taxpayers
and so it's not a very good negotiating
scenario one of the ways this manifests
is that
what I call Fairweather Keynesianism is
these state and I'm going to show you
some data just looking at state
governments but state governments in
principle if they followed and this is a
grossly oversimplified sort of Keynesian
but the idea is they should be thinking
if they really believe in Keynesianism
they should be thinking hey the economy
is booming the private sector is doing
great jobs are growing we should
throttle back lay low just do the things
that government has to do and then when
a recession hits we jump out and we we
do a lot more stimulative stuff and and
and provide it directly or indirectly a
lot more jobs we deficit spend if need
be and and help us get through the
recession and then so on we cycle cycle
back and forth that's essentially what
Keynes Ian said he talked very much
about a throttling up and down of
government spending in response to
economic cycles they don't we want the
fun part they only want to do the hey
let's increase things when when there's
a recession because you get a lot of
political points for that the throttling
back during the boom well that's no fun
so they kind of neglect that part you
know so you get this disparity where
okay the fun part is they hired a lot of
people especially at really high
salaries during the recession while the
private sector was shedding jobs but the
rest of the story is here we have this
gray line at the bottom this is how
revenue and expenditures by States would
have grown between oh two and oh eight
if they had grown revenue and
expenditures at the rate of inflation
combined with population growth so it's
a baseline it's a generous rate of
growth as you can see during that period
of time that allows for the primary
drivers of increases in government
spending the theoretical people always
say well we have to increase spending on
X because the population has grown and
there's been inflation so you can't be
spending the same as you were ten years
ago
this is what they spent during that time
so considerably more than the baseline
and this is their revenue a whole heck
of a lot more than the baseline and you
notice between 2002 and 2007 we were
going through one of them their booms
and you don't see a dip in expenditures
they're due yet so no no they were like
hey it's a boom let's spend even more
you know if it's good during a recession
it must be even better during a boom
right so we know we were talking about
Keynes the other day but now we're
saying Keynes was wrong it's always good
to spend more the burning question is
here this is this is Fred where's Fred
Fred you were complaining about
government accounting last night okay we
hit this point 2008 where suddenly
revenue fell below expenditures thanks
to recession well a there's a problem
that their expenditures didn't fall
you know the baseline dipped the revenue
depth but expenditures didn't but all
during this time notice this big space
here this is when revenue was exceeding
expenditures where'd that money go
according to official government
accounts it just doesn't exist there is
no accounting for where that money went
I think in theory there might be a way
to try to figure out but I have not
wrapped my arms around any way
from the publicly available data that
state governments provide to figure that
out it's just not there now you know
they had to spend it on something
there's limited avenues it didn't go to
Switzerland I mean that would you know
there's no way that v the legislators in
50 states could pull off a conspiracy
like that heck they can hardly walk
across the street so so I don't know
they spent it was spent by the
government in some fashion that was
simply not accounted for and you can see
it's a huge amount boy if they'd save 10
percent of that that would have just
about closed this gap a little bit more
rainy day savings would have taken care
of the recession
but no that's no fun okay so labor
unions versus taxpayers in a little bit
more direct way so aided and abetted by
Fairweather Keynesianism there's no
disincentive for for for the legislators
the elected officials to rein in these
the unions that negotiate for these
incredible and ridiculous expenditures
these incredible and ridiculous salaries
and benefits so I want to slice the
economic effects of this in a couple of
different ways so here's one just to
give you a starter okay so this is seee
I did this sort of thing where they they
stacked all these things up and they
sort of ranked the state according to
this to these evaluating these criteria
and what you get is so you see the
darker the color is the more Union
friendly the state is so this is a way
of just ranking the states by how
according to state laws that favor
collective bargaining and union power
relative to less and you can see you
know there's a pretty unsurprising
geographical distribution here I was
sort of stunned that California was only
in the not-quite and the fully fully in
the tank but and just to pay special
attention here let's see a Moz Tom Beach
let's see Julian you know so yeah you've
got okay Tennessee these are the states
that are the least friendly to Big Labor
big government labor I should say and
these are the states that are most the
laws of which are most friendly to big
government labor and I say boy starting
point for for activists is you know
what's what are these guys doing that
these guys should be doing you know
there's some pretty simple things those
those uh you know those ten criteria in
each of those there's pretty well
understood differences between the
bottom and the top states so we know
pretty clearly what legally needs to
change it's just getting the clout to do
it and I'll talk a little about that in
a minute
okay we're we're about to come out with
a report I'm giving you a preview of
some table some graphs from it so this
is where we looked at the ratio of
public and private workers in all 50
states and then we came up with some we
did so a little bit of statistical
analysis to see what kind of things are
correlated with a relatively high versus
relatively low ratio of government
workers to private workers so this
doesn't drill down into why those those
public worker numbers are higher or
lower but look at this so unfortunately
my color shading doesn't show as well
these are blue states these are red
states what this data shows is the more
Republican the voters are in a state the
more public workers you have relative to
private workers very nice
counterintuitive I think a little
finding there so somehow the more
conservative states have a higher ratio
of government workers hmm and just to
reinforce that the more Republican the
legislature is in a state the higher the
ratio of government workers to private
workers yes it defies conventional
wisdom what do you know I think because
the Republicans are very good at the
rhetoric of small government and very
poor at delivering small government you
know and then in some states I mean if
we when we parse this by state you'll
see you know a few states don't quite
fit this trend but generally speaking
these are pretty these are pretty the
statistical correlation is pretty strong
also just point out that stimulus
spending highly more stimulus spending
more of the federal federal stimulus
spent in that state equates with a
higher ratio of public workers to
private workers and a longer run tred so
leaving aside the current stimulus
spending but looking at long-run federal
aid spending even more highly so
basically the more a state sucks on the
government teat the more they're like
likely they have to have a
hi poor portion of government workers so
it's all very you know it's it's
interesting that things to to these last
two results pretty much fit I think what
anybody would would guess in advance but
the the failure of conservatives at the
state level to actually deliver on fewer
government workers is pretty striking
all right let me just tell a little
short story here about one particular
union this is California correctional
Peace Officers Association aka
California prison guards now my
next-door neighbor for many years is a
prison guard and so all my golf buddies
other than Maz are prison guards in a
California prison and they know what I
do for a living and I catch all kinds of
Hell over it I can tell you but we still
get along so but it's interesting
because I like to throw a little nuggets
at them when I come up with some new
research but this is the incarceration
rate in California for it over over a
over the last a little over 20 years you
know that's a pretty depressing figure
we're familiar with in a lot of
different dimensions I just want to
point out how sweet this is if you work
in prisons
how much sweeter is it if you represent
the guards that work in prisons because
needless to say your membership has been
skyrocketing this is in but in 20 years
they're between 80 and 2000 California
built 23 new prisons and you can see
increase the number of prison guards by
orders of magnitude this is prison
spending in California as a percentage
of the general fund is the numbers and
as a total amount the line is the total
amount the numbers of the percentage so
the percentage you know is around 10%
here it's around 10% here but the
absolute number went up quite a bit
this looks strictly at the prison guards
Union so this is this is the bars are
our membership so their membership
skyrocketed the yellow line is the
average Sal
and I'm sorry the bar is the revenue
that the Union collected from its
members the red line is the number of
members and the green line is the
average pay so not only were they
growing the number of guards during this
time but look at the pig look you know
what you need to be a prison guard in
California you need to graduate from
high school or at least take in the
weather the GRE yeah you have to take
the test and you got to go through there
a little Academy so I mean basically you
have to be physically fit and have gone
through high school so it's about as
unskilled a job as you could get now you
learn skills obvious it's not an
unskilled job but the entrance
requirements are pretty much as low as
you can go $73,000 really and this is
because California prison guards union
is extraordinarily politically powerful
in California as one Republican
legislature told me says there's only
one union that gives Republicans money
in California and we're not gonna piss
him off so the Republicans and the
Democrats are totally in the tank with
this this this Union and they in they
wield enormous clout one hand washes the
other
it's a made last year there was a huge
constant in California because they
discovered and Kennedy you talked on
their radio about this not long ago
10,000 so they discovered that guards
had systematically smuggled cell phones
in and sold them at about a thousand
bucks a pop two inmates
let's see ten thousand times a thousand
there's a little money there isn't there
and so it was found out and naughty
naughty naughty guards no one got fired
no one got penalized nothing except for
now it's a little more pain in the butt
for them to get into work because they
get searched more often that's that's
how the system reacted is well we'll try
to catch him more often and while this
controversy was brewing and radio
talk-show hosts were going on about it
editorial so
saying you've got to be kidding me Brown
said well you know what let's increase
your benefits so you know jacked up
their vacation eight weeks so these
these on these high school graduate
$75,000 a year guys also get eight weeks
vacation eight weeks vacation you know
and it sort of perks right cashing out
cashing out sick time and so forth so he
increased their benefit package during a
huge budget crisis during a recession
while they were being exposed as
obviously not public servants so go
figure
all right some solutions and I'm just
gonna shoot through these really quick
okay the worst idea to deal with the the
problems we face but the most commonly
heard one is well we obviously just need
more revenue from you people to take
care of these public servants second
worst because it's essentially the same
thing as a federal bailout I can't
believe how many people in state
government
I hear basically saying you know we're
gonna get away with this because
ultimately the federal government will
give us the money to cover what you know
what we can't do ourselves so the fact
that we our revenue has fallen below our
spending is a real inconvenience but
ultimately if we borrow to cover it we
know the federal government will bail us
out this is California strategy as they
keep running up the debt they just
altima Li they believe their
congressional members will deliver some
federal money to solve the problem
I say how about we actually take on
Union power it reduce it let's you know
and start moving more states from that
bottom five to the top five in in the
actual legislative measures that govern
collective bargaining reduce unfunded
liabilities we have to cut the benefits
and I'll talk I'll show that in a little
more detail and you've gotta cut
spending look if you've locked yourself
in to some pay and benefits or
especially benefits for workers you
can't it's very difficult to cut the
benefits for people who have already
worked for you and earned those benefits
in in a legal sense you're gonna have to
pay for that and so that means you can't
pay for all the other things you want to
pay for so
you're gonna have to start making some
cuts which is no fun right-to-work
states hey there's an amazing
correlation between right-to-work states
and states debts on average
right-to-work states have much much
lower debt burdens than non
right-to-work states I mean it's pretty
look at that total I mean it's just
amazing
so right-to-work being a right-to-work
state hey Indiana just joined the crew
three days ago four days ago
that's just fabulous but boy you want to
get this under control there's a pretty
obvious way to start it's become a
right-to-work state now this is this is
economic so private industry growth
right-to-work states versus non
right-to-work states job growth yeah
this is awesome
non right-to-work states lost a million
jobs essentially right-to-work states
gained more than three million I don't
know it to me that's it seems like that
one statistic alone in any logical world
would drive the whole train we're the
number one concern of Americans right
now is jobs well there you go
right-to-work Utah is kind of the
current model for pension reform and
this is some of the gory details which I
don't want to belabor but they had an
incredible fiscal crisis they had an
incredible pension overhang and they
just systematically in a series of bills
tackled it they shifted new employees to
define contribution instead of defined
benefit plans
they ended double dipping where
employees would retire and draw a full
retirement while also then getting a new
government job and collecting salary
you know most places have something like
well if you're working for a state
salary we hold on to your pension for
that time but a lot of places they've
negotiated no we get both so they've put
an end to that they they they shifted
they for the defined contribution the
state basically puts in a percentage
workers put in a percentage it's a
little higher for public safety workers
so we know year-on-year how much we're
going to put in it's not this highly
unpredictable defined benefit plan and
if they really really want to define
benefit that's fine but the state's
contribution is still capped so it's
really a good way of making sure they're
not digging the hole any deeper and
starting to tweak the stuff that they
already owe to reduce those liabilities
other states have done this this is not
impossible
you know Michigan switched to a divine
contribution for new employees Alaska
Utah other states now this is this is
kind of weak oh I should say as we heard
from the governor last night Puerto
Rico's shifted very recently to a
defined contribution plan for new
employees some other states have done
this sort of mixed thing which is kind
of weak because the employees get an
option and they've tried to constrain
how much of a cost that the continued
employees choosing the defined benefit
would be but it's not nearly as vigorous
a start as as a puerto rico and and you
talk done so states are starting to make
some changes but you can see this is
still only a handful of states there's
long ways to go and this is only the
first step for all of these states the
fact that new employees are not going to
be getting too outrageous of benefits
only keeps the problem from getting
bigger it doesn't deal with the fact
that you still have somewhere between 3
and 10 trillion in unfunded liabilities
cutting government spending this is this
is land and I have been working you
working on this list this is you know we
roll this out every time we meet with
any city county or our state or federal
official it's like oh you got budget
problems here you go here's your here's
your ten point checklist for how to
start getting and getting a handle on
things and you know it essentially gets
down to get more serious about budgeting
and and prioritizing your spending get
serious about privatization you own a
lot of property that's costing you a lot
of money stop it if it's not if it's not
delivering net benefits get rid of it
make privatization a systemic part of
your business
incorporate it into your planning and
you know school choice and higher
education spending you know because
education prison and education
spending or two of the fastest growing
categories you've got to get those under
control so prison reform is in there one
of those bullets too but there's a lot
of tools and all of these things that
have been done in multiple states so
it's not like you're reinventing the
wheel these are things that have been
done they work we know they work you
just have to have the political will to
do them and as you can see going all the
way back through my presentation you
know this is all about competition for
political will the unions are competing
to provide such good benefits to the
elected officials that they can stand up
to the taxpayers even though they're
raping them and and you know we're that
we the advocates on behalf of the
taxpayers and small government are
trying to give them the tools and the
intellectual arguments and focus
public's attention on the crisis to
where public pressure the only thing
that can ever beat the unions is the
public you know you cannot rely on
political readers leaders to just say I
found the courage and I'm gonna go down
in the next election as long as I get
some cuts in Union benefits that's not
going to happen except in rare occasions
and then it'll just get overturned as
soon as they're thrown out of office
it's gotta be people have to finally say
we keep we can't abide this anymore and
we're not gonna elect people that do
this I wanted to just list that we have
a lot of stuff coming up in the next
year that's related to this we're
studies Studies on pensions stays on the
on the the California prison guards sort
of taking that story I just told and
laying it out in in full flash you know
cutting spending cutting spending we're
working with the state and local budget
reforms you know in several states state
and local privatization it's a good year
for that we're working in all of these
places helping government officials
implement Lisa who we'll see later is
it's working in several places in the
country on school reform and school
budget reforms as well as school choice
reforms so you know this is a great
opportunity for reason to capitalize on
people increasingly fed up try to feed
that because that's the only way the
revolutions
happen thank you